hey Shawn buddy we need to wait on set
we love award show season and we
especially love the Nickelodeon Kids
Choice Awards the best part of this epic
annual event is all the slime let's take
a look at the funniest celebrity slime
moments ever all about slime Nickelodeon
slime goes way back
celebrities first started getting hit
with the oozy green goo back in 1988
that seems that this slimy tradition is
over 30 years old that's like really old
it's always funny watching people get
slimed but it's extra funny when they
are celebrities at the Kids Choice
Awards no one is immune to slime this
green concoction is typically made of
just two ingredients it's basically just
vanilla pudding and green food coloring
it's also really cold if you ask anyone
who has been slimed they'll tell you
that it's absolutely freezing and
sometimes it stains your clothes
that's probably why no one wears
expensive evening gowns to the Kids
Choice Awards
there was a game show called figure it
out and that show featured a lot of
slime but Nickelodeon didn't start the
slime tradition it actually dates back
to about ten years earlier a Canadian
show called you can't do that on
television invented it the Nickelodeon
adopted the tradition and made it even
more famous there is even green slime
cereal and ketchup
gross slime isn't just for the humans on
Nick green slime is also featured in an
episode of Spongebob Squarepants is it
your dream to be slimed well you too can
be covered in cold green liquid
every summer Nickelodeon hosts slime
fest in Chicago that's right it's a
whole event dedicated to slime now that
you know all about the history of slime
let's take a look at the funniest celebs
Lyman's Katy Perry one of the most
famous and most hilarious li-ming's ever
was Katy Perry the pop star was
presenting an award back in 2010 her
hair was bright blue and looking cute
she was wearing a super stylish yellow
bodycon dress she walked over to the
award box at least she believed the box
to contain the award results the box was
actually filled with
I'm the green goose shut out all over
her it was like a geyser she got
completely covered and she slipped it
was so funny taylor lautner you know him
as the good-looking werewolf from the
Twilight movies Taylor Lautner had one
of the funniest slimes ever
he was slimed in 2012 but before that he
had won a Kids Choice Award he had said
he was sad that he didn't get slimed
well he got his chance later Taylor had
shown off his moves with a bunch of
push-ups
when he finished he was hit with so much
slime be careful what you wish for
Taylor dojo Siva everyone's favorite
tween youtube star joins the slimed Hall
of Fame in 2018
Jojo seewhat performed a medley of her
hit songs she had a huge epic
performance and right as she finished
she got slimed she just sort of froze up
while getting covered in green goop you
can see the shock on her face she was
not expecting it but Jojo totally plays
it cool she just goes with it she wipes
her eyes and cheers Heidi Klum and Mel
be Heidi Klum and Mel B are probably
best known by kids as the host of
America's Got Talent
these two were swinging on a swing set
over a pool of slime they had to know
that it was coming but everyone expected
them to just fall onto the slime nope
while they were swinging the slime just
shot up at them they screamed it was one
of the funniest moments of the night
Snoop Dogg snoop Dogg may not be the
type of artists you'd expect to see on
Nickelodeon
but this rapper was not immune to the
powers of slime he was there to perform
with Big Time Rush in 2011 he was
introduced on stage and got slimed
immediately who woulda welcomed and
Snoop gets hit with a bit more than a
drizzle they sprayed him with a ton of
slime fo Rizal John Cena John Cena is
one talented guy he's a successful
wrestler who used to be a rapper and he
is a hilarious actor he's also an
amazing host for the Kids Choice Awards
he knows how to get silly at the end of
the 2018 show someone throws a bucket of
slime on him he asked
it wasn't he keeps talking and then he
gets attacked by tons of slime there was
so much slime you could barely see John
gross
NSYNC before the Jonas Brothers or why
don't we came along in sync was the
hottest boy band in town of course they
were on Kids Choice Awards these five
guys were all huddled together they knew
the slime was coming but they still
weren't prepared a wall of slime falls
all over them the best part is probably
justin timberlake's face he looks so
confused Hugh Jackman and Sandra Bullock
back in 2009 Sandra Bullock and Hugh
Jackman presented an award together and
they were in for a surprise they should
have seen it coming they walk over to
the suitcase to find out who won but
they are greeted with slime instead Hugh
yells out something in shock and Sandra
looks like she is totally over it Hugh
gets pretty into it though it's
definitely one of the best slimes ever
Shawn Mendes singer and songwriter Shawn
Mendes was a hot guest at the 2015 Kids
Choice Awards
he was totally tricked into pressing a
big red button on stage he had to know
what was coming
he got hit with so much green slime but
Shawn was hit by the slime again in 2018
and this time it was a huge surprise
Shawn was in his trailer on set someone
knocked on his door and told him he was
needed Shawn opened the door and several
guys threw buckets of slime on him let's
hope that the trailer had a working
shower Justin Bieber Justin Bieber is
definitely one of the funniest slimed
celebrities Will Smith warns him but he
doesn't understand will ducks behind him
then Justin gets hit with tons of slime
it's coming from everywhere and he just
stands there looking so confused
then the slime gets to him he Huddle's
up with Will but no one is safe from the
slime who do you want to see you get
slimed on the next Kids Choice Awards
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching hit that big red subscribe
button for more awesome videos we
promise you won't get slimed see you
next time on the things
[Music]